You have made your prediction and now it is
time to see what happens when I release the
balance.
Ready?
In three, two, one.
The balance tips towards the right, towards
the hanging, heavier ball.
But why does this happen?
Well, the best way I can think of to explain
this is that both balls displace the same
amount of water.
So they both experience the same upward buoyant
force which is equal to the weight of the
water they displace.
That is just Archimedes Principle.
But by Newton’s Third Law, that means there
must be equal and opposite forces down on
the water in both beakers.
So you would think that both beakers would
get heavier by this same amount.
Now for the hanging ball the beaker does get
heavier by this amount, because the buoyant
force is now supporting some of the weight
that used to be supported by this tension
in the string.
But it is now reduced and so beaker actually
has more weight.
But for the ping pong ball, the downward force
on the water is almost entirely counteracted
by the upward force of the tension in that
string on the bottom of the beaker.
And, therefore, the weight of this beaker
only increases by the weight of the ping pong
ball itself, whereas for the hanging ball
the weight increases by the weight of water
it displaces.
So obviously this beaker is going to end up
being heavier.
Now I want to propose an additional experiment.
What if instead of tethering the ping pong
ball to the base of this beaker, I just got
a free ping pong ball and submerged it with
my finger, just barely under the surface of
the water?
In that case, what do you think would happen
when the scale was allowed to rotate?
Would it tilt down A) towards the hanging
acrylic ball or B)
down towards the ping pong ball, which is
now just barely submerged under the water
or C) would the balance remain perfectly balanced?So
I want you to make your selection, make your
prediction by leaving a comment starting with
either A, B or C and then giving me your explanation.
And I will tally up the votes and let you
know the answer next time.